للوقوف ايضا على اخر التطورات ينضم الينا
من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن يعني في الساعه الماضيه
تحدثت عن قصف
لمدرسه وعائله من خمسه اطفال قتلت امهم
ولا يستطيعون الخروج يعني نريد معلومات
اكثر عن هذه القصه وبقيه القصص التي تاتي
مع كل قصف
اسرائيلي
نعم زين العابدين هي اسره من عائله الاسطل
محاصره داخل من داخل مدرسه كمال ناصر
بالقرب من دوار ابو حميد في وسط مدينه خان
يونس هذه الاسره هربت من نيران القصف
الاسرائيلي والتجات الى هذه المدرسه بعد
بعد استشهاد والده هؤلاء الاطفال الخمسه
برصاص قناص اسرائيلي الاسره محاصره داخل
مدرسه ككم حتى هذه الل بينهم خمس
اطفال قناص يستهدف سيده في
مدرسه يفترض انها يعني مركز ايواء لا ادري
ان كانت تابعه للون ام لا لكن يفترض انها
مدرسه لم تفقد صفه المدرسه لماذا يعني هل
هنالك اي اسباب تدعو لذلك مما تعاين تموه
على
الارض
لا توجد اي اسباب جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يستهدف المدارس والمستشفيات وجميع المرافق
حتى المقرات التابعه للامم المتحده باتت
هي الاخرى في مرمى النيران الاسرائيليه
هذه العائله على وجه التحديد لجات الى
مدرسه كمال ناصر بعد اشتداد القصف
والغارات الجويه في منطقه سكناهم لجوا الى
هذه المدرسه للاحتماء للاحتماء بها لكن
رصاص قناص اسرائيلي عاجل هذه ال الام
فقتلها على الفور ثم لجات العائله ومعها
جدهم الطاعم في السن داخل هذه المدرسه هم
يناشدون الصليب الاحمر بالوصول الى تلك
المدرسه في منطقه دوار ابو حميد لاجلاء
وانتشال ايضا جثمان
والدتهم الشهيده ايضا قصه اخرى قبل قليل
وردتنا في مدرسه الشهيد محمد الضره في
منطقه قيزان النجار هناك ثلاث عائلات
محاصره تعرضت هذه المدرسه في ساعات الصباح
الباكر لقصف مدفعي اسرائيلي ادت الى
استشهاد خمسه فلسطينيين بالاضافه الى وجود
جرحى واصابات من بين هذه العائلات الثلاث
المحاصره داخل هذه المدرسه وتمنعهم قوات
الاحتلال من الخروج من هذه المدرسه وتطلق
بين فين واخرى نيران اسلحتها اجاه هذه
العائلات الثلاث المحاصره داخل ايضا مدرسه
محمد الضره في منطقه قيزان النجار نتحدث
ان جيش الاحتلال يستهدف حتى المدارس التي
يهرب او او يلجا اليها المواطنون وسكان
المناطق التي تعرض لقصف مدفعي وغارات جويه
اسرائيليه كثيفه اليها وتستهدف
هي مدرسه كمال ناصر وايضا مدرسه محمد ره
هي مدارس حكوميه غير تابعه للرو حسب ما
وردنا من افادات شهود العيان وذويهم الذين
ياتون هنا الى مستشفى ناصر يوجهون مناشدات
للصليب الاحمر بضروره اجلائهم من تلك
المناطق العدد الشهداء يرتفع بين ساعه
واخرى هنا في مدينه خانس كنا نتحدث قبل
اقل من ساعه 16 شهيدا 17 شهيدا الان ارتفع
العدد الى 22 شهيد بعد وصول جثامين اربعه
اطفال من منزل عائله الاغا في منطقه السطر
الغربي احد المواطنين تمكن عبر عربه من
الوصول الى ذلك المنزل في منطقه السطر
الغربي وانتشال جثامين الشهداء الاربعه
وهم اطفال وايصالهم الى اقرب نقطه امنه
لسيارات الاسعاف التي نقلتهم بدورها الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي احن نتحدث عن خمس شهداء
في مستشفى في مدرسه الدره شهيده قتلت
برصاص قناص اسرائيل في مدرسه كمال ناصر
العدد مرشح للارتفاع بشكل كبير لكن قوات
الاحتلال تحظر وتمنع على سيارات الاسعاف
من الوصول الى المناطق خاصه التي تشهد
اشتباكات وقصف مدفع عنيف تحديدا في منطقه
وسط البلد منطقه السطر الغربي منطقه قيزان
النجار حي المناره جورت اللوت هذه المناطق
الثلاث الاخيره التي ذكرتها تتعرض منذ
ساعات الفجر وحتى هذه اللحظه الى غارات
جويه كثيفه وايضا قصف مدفعي كثيف ادى
لانتشال 18 شهيدا فقط من منطقه قيزان
النجار وجرتو اللوت
وايضا حي المناره والتي تقع الى الجنوب
الشرقي من مدينه خانين والتي تشهد توغلا
بريا منذ ساعات الفجر الاولى وايضا
اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال في عدد من هذه المناطق
نفها كان في محيط مقر كليه العلوم
والتكنولوجيا في منطقه خيزان النجار زين
العابدين مؤمن الشرافي ايضا من الاشياء
اللافته هو استهداف
السيارات المتحركه في مناطق يفترض انها
مناطق امنه كما حدث مع زميلنا وابن زميلنا
حمزه الدحدوح والزميل مصطفى ثريه يوم
امس يعني حدثنا عن مساله
السيارات التي
تستهدف ولماذا تستهدف في مناطق امله يعني
يعني عاده ما نسمع منكم انتم مراسلين في
غزه انه لا يوجد مكان امن لكن هل هنالك اي
شيء يمكن للفلسطيني في غزه ان يفعله و
ويكون فيه امنا هذا
الشيء لا يوجد شيء او طريقه او اسلوب او
اداه ممكن ان توفر لك الامن والحمايه س
سواء للطاقم الصحفي او للمدنيين او حتى
لعائلتك التي نزحت الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
في مدينه رفح جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دفع
باكثر من نصف سكان قطاع غزه اكثر من مليون
نسمه يتواجدون داخل مدينه رفح وفي المنطقه
الحدوديه القريبه من
الحدود المصريه حتى في مدينه رفح التي
يتواجد فيها اكثر من نصف سكان قطاع غزه
تتعرض للقصف والغارات الاسرائيليه قبل
قليل استهدفت ط ئره حربيه اسرائيليه سياره
مدنيه كانت تسير في شارع الزر بالقرب من
دوار زعرب في مدينه رفح ادت هذه الغاره
التي استهدفت السياره المدنيه الى استشهاد
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واصابه عدد اخر بجروح
متفاوته وصلوا الى مستشفى الكويتي في
مدينه رفع والحديث عن اصابات خطيره
ايضا ومن المرشح والمتوقع ان يرتفع عدد
الشهداء الاكثر من ثلاث شهداء حتى
السيارات المدنيه حتى المدارس التابعه
للون والمدارس الحكوميه المستشفيات
والمراكز الطبيه حتى الاراضي الزراعيه
التي ينصب بها النازحون خيامهم في ظل هذا
البرد القارس تستهدف من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه كما حدث في منطقه ميراج امس عائله
ابو نج تحدث عن 18 شهيدا وهم نازحين
استهدفتهم الطائرات الحربيه في منطقه
زراعيه وفي خيمه يعيشون في خيمه شكرا
جزيلا لك مؤمن شرافي من خان يونس